some critics as you've heard say jeff
bezos achievement came at the expense
of his workers and american taxpayers
mark strossman joins us from van horn
texas with more on that mark good
morning
good morning anthony i mean blue origin
of course is thrilled by its first
manned space flight
and this community is too space has
given van horn
a new identity but critics say this
billionaire space race isn't just the
latest example
of inequality here on earth
tuesday's launch was a picture-perfect
promo for blue origin's new shepard
rocket
and the future of space tourism you
obviously have grander space ambitions
than going to the edge
of it did this moment motivate you to
push deeper into the cosmos hell yes
billionaire jeff bezos realized a
childhood dream
one he shared with his brother mark 18
year old dutch student oliver damon
and 82 year old wally funk the aviation
pioneer finally earned her astronaut
wings
more than 60 years after nasa denied her
chance at space
i want to go again fast
[Laughter]
but one of bezos's post-launch thank
yous
stood out i also i want to thank uh
every amazon employee and every amazon
customer
because you guys paid for all this labor
organizers pounced
bashing bezos and amazon for allegedly
underpaying and mistreating warehouse
workers
in a statement to cbs news the teamsters
union hoping to unionize amazon
said if jeff bezos really wants to thank
amazon workers he should listen to their
demands
rather than perpetuating a highly
exploitative business model
other critics pointed to this propublica
investigation of irs tax data
it found bezos's personal fortune grew
by a 127 billion dollars
from 2006 to 2018 while paying
1.4 billion in taxes a tax
rate of about 1.1 percent this is blue
moon
bezos intends to use his fortune to
build a space empire
critics say that money could be better
spent solving problems
here on earth bezos says he can do both
quote we have lots of problems in the
here and now on earth
and we need to work on those and we need
to look to the future
we also reached out to amazon the
company had no comment
but commercial space has launched and it
does seem here to stay vlad
all right mark strossman and van horn
thank you mark